hey it's car Michael and I'm here with
Diana night Andale and what you're about
to watch is the official version of The
Strangest Secret so if you want to
support the night Gale family this is
the version to watch and share Dana you
want to share something I do I want to
tell you to join the millions of people
from around the world who have listened
to this recording and it's changed their
lives for the better
enjoy I'd like to tell you about The
Strangest Secret in the world world not
long ago Albert schwitzer the Great
doctor and Nobel Prize winner was being
interviewed in London and a reporter
asked him doctor what's wrong with men
today the great doctor was silent a
moment and then he said men simply don't
think and it's about this that I want to
talk with you we live today in a golden
age this is an era that man has looked
forward dreamed of and worked toward for
thousands of years but since it's here
we pretty well take it for granted we in
America are particularly fortunate to
live in the richest land that ever
existed on the face of the earth a land
of abundant opportunity for everyone but
do you know what happens let's take a
100 men who start even at the age of 25
do you have any idea what will happen to
those men by the time they're 65 these
100 men who all start even at the age of
25 believe they're going to be
successful if you asked any one of these
men if he wanted to be a success he'd
tell you that he did and you'd notice
that he was eager to life that there was
a certain Sparkle to his eye and
erectness to his carriage and life
seemed like a pretty interesting
adventure to him but by the time there's
65 one will be rich four will be
financially independent five will still
be working 54 will be broke now think a
moment out of the 100 only five make the
grade why do so many fail what has
happened to the sparkle that was there
when they were 25 what's become of the
dream the hopes the plans and why is
there such a large disparity between
what these men intended to do and what
they actually accomplished when we say
about 5% achieve success we have to
define success and here's the definition
success is the progressive realization
of a worthy ideal if a man is working
toward a predetermined goal and knows
where he's going that man is a success
if he's not doing that he's a failure
success is the Progressive realization
of a worthy ideal R May the
distinguished psychiatrist wrote a
wonderful book called man search for
himself and in this book he says the
opposite of courage in our society is
not cowardice it is Conformity and there
you have the trouble today it's
Conformity people acting like everyone
else without knowing why without knowing
where they're going now think of it in
America right now there are over 14
million people 65 years of age and old
over and about 13 million of these 14
million are broke they're dependent on
someone else for life's Necessities now
we learn to read by the time we're seven
we learn to make a living by the time
we're 25 usually by that time we're not
only making a living we're supporting a
family and yet by the time we're 65 we
haven't learned how to become
financially independent in the richest
land that has ever been known why we can
form and the trouble is that we're
acting like the wrong percentage group
the 95% who don't succeed now why do
these people conform well they don't
know really these people believe that
their lives are shaped by circumstances
by things that happen to them by
exterior forces they're outer-directed
people a survey was made one time that
covered a lot of men working men and
these men were asked this question why
do you work why do you get up in the
morning 19 out of 20 had no idea if you
ask them they'll say everyone goes to
work in the morning
and that's the reason they do it because
everyone else is doing it now let's get
back to our definition of success who
succeeds the only man who succeeds is
the man who is progressively realizing a
worthy ideal he's the man who says I'm
going to become this and then begins to
work toward that goal I'll tell you who
the successful people are a success is
the school teacher who's teaching school
because that's what she wanted to do the
success is the woman who's a wife and
mother because she wanted to become a
wife and mother and is doing doing a
good job of it the success is the man
who runs the Corner Gas Station because
that's what he wanted to do the success
is the successful salesman who wants to
become a top-notch Salesman and grow and
build with his organization a success is
anyone who is doing deliberately a
predetermined job because that's what he
decided to do deliberately but only one
out of 20 does that that's why today
there isn't really any competition
unless we make it for ourselves instead
of competing all we have to do is create
now for 20 years I looked for the key
which would determine what would happen
to a human being was there a key I
wanted to know which would make the
future a promise that we could foretell
to a large extent was there a key that
would guarantee a person's becoming
successful if he only knew about it and
knew how to use it well there is such a
key and I found it have you ever
wondered why so many men work so hard
and honestly without ever achieving
anything in particular and others don't
seem to work hard and yet seem to get
everything they have the Magic Touch
you've heard them say that about someone
everything he touches turns to gold and
have you ever noticed that a man who
becomes successful tends to continue to
become successful and on the other hand
have you noticed how a man who is a
failure tends to continue to fail it's
because of goals some of us have them
some don't people with goals succeed
because they know where they're going
now think of a ship leaving a harbor and
think of it with the complete Voyage
mapped out in and plan the captain and
crew know exactly where it's going and
how long it will take it has a definite
goal
99,999 times out of 10,000 it will get
to where it started out to get now let's
take another ship just like the first
only let's not put a crew on it or a
captain at the helm let's give it no
aiming point no goal no destination we
just start the engines and let it go I
think you'll agree with me that if it
gets out of the harbor at all it will
either sink or wind up on some deserted
Beach a derel it can't go any place
because it has no destination and no
guidance it's the same with a human
being take the salesman for example
there is no other person in the world
today with the future of a good salesman
selling is the world's highest paid
profession if we're good at it and if we
know where we're going every company
needs top-notch salesman and they reward
those men the sky is the limit for them
but how many can you find someone once
said the human race is fixed not to
prevent the strong from winning but to
prevent the weak from losing the
American economy today can be likened to
a convoy in time of war the entire
economy is slowed down to protect its
weakest link just as the Convoy had to
go at the speed that would permit its
slowest vessel to remain in formation
that's why it's so easy to make a living
today it takes no particular brains or
talent to make a living and support a
family today so we have a plateau of
so-called security if that's what a
person's looking for
but we do have to decide how high above
this Plateau we want to aim for now
let's get back to The Strangest Secret
in the world the story that I wanted to
tell you today why do men with goals
succeed in life and men without them
fail well let me tell you something
which if you really understand it will
alter your life immediately if you
understand completely what I'm going to
tell you from this moment on your life
will never be the same again you'll
suddenly find that good luck just seems
to be attracted to you the things you
want just seem to fall in line and from
now on you won't have the problems the
worries the gwing lump of anxiety that
perhaps you've experienced before doubt
fear well they'll be things of the past
here's the key to success and the key to
failure we become what we think about
now let me say that again we become what
we think about through throughout all
history the great wise men and teachers
philosophers and Prophets have disagreed
with one another on many different
things it is only on this one point that
they are in complete and unanimous
agreement listen to what Marcus aelius
the great Roman Emperor said he said a
man's life is what his thoughts make of
it Disraeli said this everything comes
if a man will only wait I have brought
Myself by long meditation to the
conviction that a human being with a
settled purpose must accomplish it and
that nothing can resist a will that will
stake even existence for its fulfillment
Ralph Waldo Emerson said this a man is
what he thinks about all day long
William James said the greatest
discovery of my generation is that human
beings can alter their lives by altering
their attitudes of mind and he also said
we need Only In Cold Blood act as if the
thing in question were real and it will
become infallibly Real by growing into
such a connection with our life that it
will become real it will become so knit
with habit and emotion that our interest
in it will be those which characterize
belief he also said this if you only
care enough for a result you will almost
certainly attain it if you wish to be
rich you will be rich if you wish to be
learned you will be learned if you wish
to be good you will be good only you
must then really wish these things and
wish them exclusively and not wish it
the at the same time a hundred other
incompatible things just as
strongly in the Bible you read in Mark
9:23 if thou canst believe all things
are possible to him that believeth Dr
Norman Vincent Peele said this this is
one of the greatest laws in the universe
fervently do I wish I had discovered it
as a very young man it dawned upon me
much later in life and I found it to be
one of the greatest if not my greatest
discovery outside of my relationship to
God and the Great Law briefly and simply
stated is that if you think in negative
terms you'll get negative results if you
think in positive terms you will achieve
positive results that is the simple fact
which is at the basis of an astonishing
law of prosperity and success in three
words believe and succeed William
Shakespeare put it this way our doubts
are traitors and make us lose the good
we oft might win by fearing to attempt
George Bernard Shaw said people are
always blaming their circumstances for
what they are I don't believe in
circumstances the people who get on in
this world are the people who get up and
look for the circumstances they want and
if they can't find them make
them well it's pretty apparent isn't
it and every person who discovered this
for a while believed that he was the
first one to work it out we become what
we think about now it stands to reason
that a person who's thinking about a
concrete and worthwhile goal is going to
reach it because that's what he's
thinking about and we become what we
think about conversely the man who has
no goal who doesn't know where he's
going and whose thoughts must therefore
be thoughts of confusion and anxiety and
fear and worry becomes what he thinks
about his life becomes one of
frustration fear anxiety and worry and
if he thinks about nothing he becomes
nothing now how does it work why do we
become what we think about well I'll
tell you how it works as far as we know
now to do this I want to tell you about
a situation that parallels the human
mind suppose a farmer has some land and
it's good fertile land now the land
gives the farmer a choice he may plant
in that land whatever he chooses the
land doesn't care it's up to the farmer
to make the decision now remember we're
comparing the human mind with the land
because the mind like the land doesn't
care what you plant in it it will return
what you plant but it doesn't care what
you plant now let's say that the farmer
has two seeds in his hand one is a seed
of corn the other is Nightshade a deadly
poison he digs two little holes in the
earth and he plants both seeds one corn
the other Nightshade he covers up the
holes Waters and takes care of the land
and what will happen invariably the land
will return what is planted as it's
written in the Bible as ye sow so shall
ye reap remember remember the land
doesn't care it will return poison in
just as wonderful abundance as it will
corn so up come the two plants one corn
one poison now the human mind is far
more fertile far more incredible and
mysterious than the land but it works
the same way it doesn't care what we
plant success failure a concrete
worthwhile goal or confusion misunder
understanding fear anxiety and so on but
what we plant it will return to us you
see the mind is the last great
unexplored continent on the earth it
contains riches beyond our wildest
dreams it will return anything we want
to
plant now you might say well if that's
true why don't people use their minds
more well I think they figured out an
answer to that too our mind comes as
standard equipment at Birth it's free
and things that are given to us for
nothing we place little value on things
that we pay money for we value the
Paradox is that exactly the reverse is
true everything that's really worthwhile
in life came to us free our mind our
soul our body our hopes our dreams our
Ambitions our intelligence our love of
family and children and friends all
these Priceless possessions are free but
the things that cost us money are
actually very cheap and can be replaced
at any time a good man can be completely
wiped out and make another Fortune he
can do that several times even if our
home burns down we can rebuild it but
the things we got for nothing we can
never replace the human mind isn't used
merely because we take it for granted
familiarity breeds contempt it can do
any kind of job we assign to it but
generally speaking we use it for little
jobs instead of big important ones
universities have proved that most of us
are operating on about 10% of our
abilities decide now what is it you want
plant your goal in your mind it's the
most important decision you'll ever make
in your entire life do you want to be an
outstanding salesman a better worker at
your particular job do you want to go
places in your company in your community
all you've got to do is plant that seed
in your mind care for it work steadily
toward your goal and it will become a
reality it not only will there's no way
that it cannot you see that is a law
like the laws of Sir Isaac Newton the
laws of gravity if you get on top of a
building and jump off you'll always go
down you'll never go up and it's the
same with all the other laws of nature
they always work they're inflexible
think about your goal in a relaxed
positive way picture yourself in your
mind's eye as having already achieved
this goal see yourself doing the things
you will be doing when you've reached
your goal ours has been called the PHA
barbital age the age of ulcers and
nervous breakdowns at a time when
medical research has raised us to a new
plateau of Good Health and Longevity far
too many of us worry ourselves into an
early grave trying to cope with things
in our own little personal ways without
learning a few great laws that will take
care of everything for us these things
we bring on ourselves through our
habitual way of thinking every one of us
is the sum tootal of his own thoughts he
is where he is because that is exactly
where he really wants to be whether
he'll admit that or not each of us must
live off the fruit of his thoughts in
the future because what you think today
and tomorrow next month the next year
will mold your life and determine your
future you're Guided by your mind
I remember one time I was driving
through Arizona and I saw one of those
giant Earth moving machines roaring
along the road at about 35 mph with what
looked like 20 tons of dirt in it a
tremendous incredible machine and there
was a little man perched way up on top
with the wheel in his hands guiding it
and as I drove along I was struck by the
similarity of that machine to the human
mind just suppose you're sitting at the
controls of such a vast source of energy
are you going to sit back and fold your
arms and let it run itself into a ditch
or are you going to keep both hands
firmly on the wheel and control and
direct this power to a specific
worthwhile purpose it's up to you you're
in the driver's
seat you see the very law that gives us
success is a two-edged sword we must
control our thinking the same rule that
can lead a man to a life of success
wealth happiness and all the things he's
ever dreamed of for himself and his
family that very very same law can lead
him into the gutter it's all in how he
uses it for good or for bad this is The
Strangest Secret in the
world now why do I say it's strange and
why do I call it a secret actually it
isn't a secret at all it was first
promulgated by some of the earliest wise
men and it appears again and again
throughout the Bible but very few people
have learned it understand it that's why
it's strange and why for some equally
strange reason it virtually remains a
secret I believe that you could go out
and walk down the main street of your
town and ask one man after another what
the secret of success is and you
probably wouldn't run into one man in a
month who could tell you now this
information is enormously valuable to us
if we really understand it and apply it
it's valuable to us not only for our own
lives but the lives of those around us
our family employees Associates and
Friends life should be an exciting
Adventure it should never be a boore a
man should live fully be alive he should
be glad to get out of bed in the morning
he should be doing a job he likes to do
because he does it well one time I heard
Grove Patterson make a speech the
editor-in chief of the Toledo daily
blade and as he concluded his speech he
said something that I've never forgotten
he said something like this my years in
the newspaper business have convinced me
of several things among them that people
are basically good and that we came from
some place
and we're going
someplace so we should make our time
here an exciting
Adventure the architect of the universe
didn't Build A Stairway leading
nowhere and the greatest teacher of all
the carpenter from The Plains of Galilee
gave us the secret time and time again
as ye
believe so shall it be done unto
you on side number one of this record
I've explained The Strangest Secret in
the world and how it works now on this
side I want to explain how you can prove
to yourself the enormous returns
possible in your own life by putting
this secret to a practical test I want
you to make a
test that will last 30
days now it isn't going to be easy if
you'll give it a good try it will
completely change your life for the
better back in the 17th century Sir
Isaac Newton the English method
mathematician a natural philosopher gave
us some natural laws of physics which
apply as much to human beings as they do
to the movement of bodies in the
universe now one of these laws is that
for every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction simply stated as it
applies to you and me it means we can
achieve nothing without paying the price
the results of your 30-day experiment
will be in direct proportion to the
effort you put forth to be a doctor you
must pay the price of long years of
difficult study to be successful in
selling and remember that each of us
succeeds to the extent of his ability to
sell selling our families on our ideas
selling education in schools selling our
children on the advantages of living the
good and honest life selling our
Associates and employees on The
Importance of Being exceptional people
to of course the profession of selling
itself but to be successful in selling
our way to the good life we must be
willing to pay the price now what is
that price well it's many things first
it's understanding emotionally as well
as intellectually that we literally
become what we think about that we must
control our thoughts if we're to control
Our Lives it's understanding fully that
as you sow so shall you reap secondly
it's cutting away all the Fetters from
the mind in permitting it to soar as it
was divinely designed to do it's the
realization that your limitations are
self imposed and that the opportunities
for you today are enormous beyond belief
it's rising above narrow-minded
pettiness and
Prejudice thirdly to use all your
courage to force yourself to think
positively on your own problem to set a
definite and clearly defined goal for
yourself to let your marvelous mind
think about your goal from all possible
angles to let your imagination speculate
freely upon many different possible
solutions to refuse to believe there are
any circumstances sufficiently strong to
defeat you in the accomplishment of your
purpose to act promptly and decisively
when your course is clear and to keep
constantly aware of the fact that you
are at this moment standing in the
middle of your own acre of diamonds as
Russell Conwell used to point out fourth
save at least 10% of what you
earn it's also remembering that no
matter what your present job it has has
enormous possibilities if you're willing
to pay the price now let's just go over
the important points in the price each
of us must pay to achieve the wonderful
life that can be ours it is of course
worth any price one you will become what
you think about two remember the word
imagination let your mind soar three
courage concentrate on your goal every
day four save 10% of what you earn and
action
ideas are worthless unless we act on
them now I'll try to outline the 30-day
test I want you to make now keep in mind
that you have nothing to lose by making
this test and everything you could
possibly want to gain there are two
things that may be said of everyone each
of us wants something and each of us is
afraid of something I want you to write
on a card what it is you want more than
anything else it may be more money
perhaps you'd like to double your income
or make a specific amount of money it
may be a beautiful home it may be
success at your job it may be a
particular position in life it could be
a more harmonious family each of us want
something write down on your card
specifically what it is that you want
make sure it's a single goal and clearly
defined you needn't show it to anyone
but carry it with you so that you can
look at it several times a day think
about it in a cheerful relaxed positive
way each morning when you get up and
immediately you have something to work
for something to get out of bed for
something to live for look at it every
chance you get during the day and just
before going to bed at night as you look
at it remember that you must become what
you think about and since you're
thinking about your goal you realize
that soon it will be yours in fact it's
yours really the moment you write it
down and begin to think about it look at
the abundance all around you as you go
about your daily business you have as
much right to this abundance as any
other living creature it's yours for the
asking now we come to the difficult part
difficult because it means the formation
of what is probably a brand new habit
and new habits are not easily formed
once formed however it'll follow you for
the rest of your
life stop thinking about what it is you
fear each time a fearful or negative
thought comes into your Consciousness
replace it with a mental picture of your
positive and worthwhile goal there will
come times when you'll feel like giving
up it's easier for a human being to
think negatively than positively that's
why only 5% is successful you must begin
now to place yourself in that group for
30 days you must take control of your
mind it will think only about what you
permitt it to think each day for this
30-day test do more than you have to do
in addition to maintaining a cheerful
positive outlook give of yourself more
than you've ever done before do this
knowing that your returns in life must
be in direct proportion to what you give
the moment you decide on a goal to work
toward you're immediately a successful
person you're then in that rare and
successful category of people who know
where they're going out of every hundred
people you belong to the top five don't
concern yourself too much with how
you're going to achieve your goal leave
that completely to a power greater than
yourself all you have to do is know
where you're going the answers will come
to you of their own
accord remember these words from The
Sermon on the Mount and remember them
well keep them constantly before you
this month of your
test ask and it shall be given you seek
and ye shall find knock and it shall be
opened unto you for everyone that
askthe findeth and to him that knock
it shall be opened it's as marvelous and
as simple as that in fact it's so simple
that in our seemingly complicated world
it's difficult for an adult to
understand that all he needs is a
purpose and Faith for 30 days do your
best if you're a Salesman go at it as
you've never done before not in hectic
fashion but with a calm cheerful
assurance that time well spent will give
you the abundance and return you deserve
and want if you're a homemaker devote
your 30-day test to complete giving of
yourself without thinking about
receiving anything in return and you'll
be amazed at the difference it makes in
your life no matter what your job do it
as you've never done it before for 30
days and if you've kept your goal before
you every day you'll wonder and Marvel
at this new life you
found Dorothy AB brand outstanding
editor and writer discovered it for
herself and tells about it in her fine
book wake up and live her entire
philosophy is reduced to the words act
as though it were impossible to
fail she made her own test with
sincerity and faith and her entire life
was changed to one of overwhelming
success now you make your test for 30
full days don't start your test until
you've made up your mind to stick with
it you see by being persistent you're
demonstrating Faith persistence is
simply another word for faith if you
didn't didn't have faith you would never
persist if you should fail during your
first 30 days by that I mean suddenly
find yourself overwhelmed by negative
thoughts you've got to start over again
from that point and go 30 more
days gradually your new habit will form
until you find yourself one of that
wonderful minority to whom virtually
nothing is impossible don't forget the
card it's vitally important as you begin
this new way of living on one side of
the card write your goal whatever it may
be on the other side write the words
we've quoted from The Sermon on the
Mount ask and it shall be given you seek
and you shall find knock and it shall be
opened unto
you in your spare time during your test
period read books that will help you
inspirational books like the Bible
dorothia Brands wake up and live the
magic of Believing by Claude Bristol and
other books that instruct and Inspire
nothing great was ever accomplished
without inspiration see that during
these crucial first 30 days your own
inspiration is kept at a peak above all
don't
worry worry brings fear and fear is
crippling the only thing that can cause
you to worry during your test is trying
to do it all yourself no know that all
you have to do is hold your goal before
you everything else will take care of
itself remember also to keep calm and
cheerful calm and cheerful don't let
Petty things annoy you get you off
course now since making this test is
difficult some may say well why should I
bother well look at the alternative
no one wants to be a failure no one
really wants to be a mediocre individual
no one wants a life constantly filled
with worry fear and
frustration therefore remember that you
must reap that which you sow if you sow
negative thoughts your life will be
filled with negative things if you sow
positive thoughts your life will be
cheerful successful and
positive now gradually you'll have a
tendency to for for get what you've
heard on this record play it often keep
reminding yourself of what you must do
to form this new habit gather your whole
family about and listen to what's been
said here at regular
intervals you know most men will tell
you that they want to make money without
understanding the law the only people
who make money work in the mint the rest
of us must earn money this is what
causes those who keep looking for
something for nothing or a free ride to
fail in life the only way to earn money
is by providing people with services or
products which are needed and useful we
exchange our product or service for the
other man's money therefore the law is
that our financial return will be in
direct proportion to our
service success is not the result of
making money making money is the result
of success and success is in direct
proportion
to our service most people have this law
backwards they believe that you're
successful if you earn a lot of
money the truth is that you can only
earn money after you're successful it's
like the story of the man who sat in
front of the stove and said to it give
me heat and then I'll add the wood how
many men and women do you know or do you
suppose there are today who take the
same attitude toward life there are
millions
we've got to put the fuel in before we
can expect heat likewise we've got to be
of service first before we can expect
money don't concern yourself with the
money be of service build work Dream
create do this and you'll find there's
no limit to the prosperity and abundance
that will come to you Prosperity is
founded upon a law of mutual Exchange
any person who contributes to Prosperity
must prosper in turn
himself sometimes the return will not
come from those you serve but it must
come to you from someplace for that is
the
law for every action there is an equal
and opposite reaction as you go daily
through your 30-day test period remember
that your success will always be
measured by the quality and quantity of
service you render and money is a yard
stick for measuring this service no man
can get rich himself unless he enriches
others there are no exceptions to a law
you can drive down any Street in America
and from your car estimate the service
that's being rendered by the people
living on that street had you ever
thought of this yard stick before it's
interesting some like ministers and
Priests and other devoted people measure
their returns in the realm of the
spiritual but again their returns are
equal to their servs once this law is
fully understood any thinking person can
tell his own fortune if he wants more he
must be of more service to those from
whom he receives his return if he wants
less he has only to reduce this
service this is the price you must pay
for what you
want if you believe you can enrich
Yourself by deluding others you can only
End by deluding yourself
it may take some time but just as surely
as you breathe you'll get back what you
put out don't ever make the mistake of
thinking you can avert this it's
impossible the prisons and the streets
where the lonely walk are filled with
people who tried to make new laws just
for
themselves we may avoid the laws of man
but there are greater laws that cannot
be broken
an outstanding medical doctor recently
pointed out six steps that will help you
realize success one set yourself a
definite goal two quit running yourself
down three stop thinking of all the
reasons why you cannot be successful and
instead think of all the reasons why you
can four trace your attitudes back
through your childhood and try to
discover where you first got the idea
you couldn't be a success if that's the
way you've been thinking five change the
image you have of yourself by writing
out a description of the person you
would like to be and six act the part of
the successful person you have decided
to
become live this new way and the
floodgates of abundance will open and
pour over you more riches than you may
have dreamed existed money
yes lots of it but what's more important
you'll have
peace you'll be in that wonderful
minority who lead calm cheerful
successful lives start today you have
nothing to lose but you have a life to
win this is all Nightingale and thank
you to see the very last time that Jim
ran did a video interview check it out
right there next to me I think love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there Jim ran was one of the fathers of
personal development he was Tony
robins's personal mentor and influenced
other greats like Jack Canfield Mark
Victor Hansen and Brian Tracy